shei somebody that's he started off as
an assassin
it's actually quite naive on that
actually he goes through a
transformation but from them we can
actually expect a much more focused
serious darker character it is it fair
to say that we're playing as the bad guy
in this game because you know anybody
who's played Assassin's Creed we've been
kind of conditioned to feel that
Templars are the bad guys well one of
the things we were we actually wanted to
show is that assassins and Templars that
they're both working towards the same
goal they both want world peace but they
actually both take different approaches
and different means they have they have
different values so for us what we
actually want the the player to to feel
that the the Templars are sometimes
they're justified what are the ways that
playing as a Templar actually affects
like the real core fundamental elements
became a lot of this were actually
leaving up to the players
I mean we've created a situation where
by playing with the mechanics and
actually bringing new tools to the
player
we've gone very much now on on setting
up an encounter and experience for the
player and then say to the player really
do it your way what's the best way to
easily achieve those those objectives
something that's very much down to the
player we focused a lot on manipulation
this forces is key to the Templar
experience you don't have to be evil not
every form of manipulation needs to
result in death but it's your choice
very much the the whole questions here
when we started the game was well you're
now hunting assassins you know how do
you assassinate an assassin what is it
you do that actually gives you to the
end of that whole plus the the idea of
the temple of values
so really we wanted to push these core
elements it's about actually now you've
been fighting with the assassins now
it's your turn to start hunting
assassins now what does that mean it
means that you've got guys that can air
assassinate you you've got guys that
will throw smoke bombs at you you've got
people that we've had several so many
games now are actually experiencing what
it is to throw smoke bombs and what it
is to air assassinate you
now let's look at it from the other
angle this time you're going to get it
done to you if you're not careful I do
have to ask you one question about the
naval combat in the game a lot of people
are very surprised by how well that
turned out in Assassin's Creed 4
definitely wasn't the star of the show
what's what's going on with the naval
combat stuff we give you a new ship the
Morrigan is it's smaller it's faster
than the jackdaw this allows you to turn
tighter avoid shots navigate that the
the the world a lot more accurately more
smoothly more effectively we've passed
over all the weaponry so that name is
probably the Templar weapons that we saw
like that the Karin AIDS and the burning
oil well also we will worked on the AI
for the for the ships that you encounter
so now they make better decisions their
navigation is improved as well we built
on great existing technology and decided
that we wanted to put all of it further
to the next level to really give you a
much more powerful feeling when you're
at the wheel lover of of the Morrigan's
but also to make you feel actually doke
that there is more of a threat coming
from enemy ships that you encounter the
intro of the gentleman that I played
zooms in on the ship we see a familiar
face on board mr. Payton Kenway yes what
can you tell me about the relationship
there what's going on with him and Shay
Patrick um I can't go into great deal of
detail because I really don't want to
give any any story spoilers what I can
tell you is that that that what we're
doing in roguettes we're completing the
the Kenway saga we first meet Haytham
when actually he's with Edward in in the
Assassin's Creed 4 but actually what's
happened to the the Brotherhood and the
Templars at the end of Assassin's Creed
4 certainly you feel like that the
Templars they're sorry the assassins are
in the ascendancy and by the time you
get to Assassin's Creed 3 the
Brotherhood is broken so a lot of people
are asking us okay how come we can't
ignore Haytham in this he's there in
Assassin's Creed 4 he's there in
Assassin's Creed 3 we're completing the
Kenway at the Kenway saga and and
Haytham is a core person in this
[Music]